okay I wanted to take a second and talk
about the elections again of course we
have the elections last week and if
you're a Democrat you're a lot of pain
right now if you're a Republican you're
feeling good everybody's showing that
map where the whole country looks red
except there's a little blue around the
water cuz that's where the Democrats are
apparently they want an easy escape they
wanna be able to swim somewhere real
quick in case the Republicans get out of
control but what I want to talk about
was sort of the narrative that was going
down for months and months and months
before the election actually took place
if you had watch the media constantly on
Fox on MSNBC on CNN on all the the
National stations what they kept saying
was all look at the Republican Party
their fracturing the Republican Party
the Tea Party is going off the deep end
and the regular Republicans nobody likes
them they kept saying that while also
implying that I everybody loves the
Democrats right everybody's now with
Obama everybody loves okay and there was
this constant thing like always the
Republican Party done are they gonna be
buried so what this was making me think
now that we've seen the results of this
thing and it is very clear that it
wasn't the Republicans that fractured if
anything it was the Democrats that
fractured especially the Democrats that
ran away from Obama before the election
uh what was make me think is that it's
so important to make decisions for
yourself and not listen to what the
media is constantly drubbing in your
mind now of course i yeah i'm part of
the media here so take this with a grain
of salt of course um but remember that
when they keep telling you that
something is happening it doesn't mean
it's actually true and pundits are wrong
all the time look at all the wars that
we fight where they die it's gonna be so
easy the original Rockwell yeah no
problem we're gonna knock this thing out
real easy no problem and it just rarely
is ever true these people rarely get any
of this stuff right they rarely get
predictions right they rarely get any of
the things that they're throwing at you
correct so partly they were just you
know look there's a lot of liberal
people in the media and what they wanted
you to believe is that the Republicans
are in for hurting and then what that
ends up doing is sometimes a game it
makes the Democrats go I guess I don't
have to vote because the Republicans are
in for a real hurt so on either side
what whatever side you're on try to
pilfer out whatever truth you can get
out of the media instead of just
listening to their talking points
because clear
as his evidence last week it is not
always the case so find some truth it's
out there